hello everyone I hope you're still
having an excellent the day we mentioned
that we are going to cover at least one
more game from round four of the 2019
FIBA World Team Championship so here it
is it's Sweden verse Sweden vs.
Azerbaijan our Niels Gonzalez versus
Arkady in a ditch it's a really an
interesting game with a lot of things
going on and it's one of those games
that you just don't believe could go
wrong but they do especially if you're
playing the game so without further ado
let's check out the game unfortunately I
don't have any photos of this particular
match but I'm sure we're gonna get some
tomorrow so let's check it out Greendale
who says the white pieces and he opens
with E for with e5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and now comes Bishop to b5 Duru
Lopez and Knight to f6 the Berlin
defence and I know what you're saying
how could we have an exciting game in
the Berlin defence but well bear with me
the 3 d6
we have castles and here a Bishop d7 all
standard stuff for the Berlin rook to e1
and now black just castles we have c3 a6
pushing the bishop back push up to a
four and now rook to e8 making a room
for the bishop on f8 so the rookin
controlled e-file but also the bishop
will be an excellent defender as you'll
see in the game h3 by white Bishop to f8
and now comes c4 and this has all been
played plenty of times before some more
notable games are a circuit kirkin vs
Bassam amin i in the 2016 Olympic wather
by John aware Knights the d7 was played
but also there is a game Alexander Greek
versus a Gregory quedan of in 2018 isle
of man chest first of all also Knight to
d7 was played but here we have Bishop to
d7 so already a surprise from the
from Arkady NIDA to push up to d7 and
now we have a completely new game so
it's black who surprises in this line
Bishop to e3 white continues developing
and now Knights the b8 hoping the trade
of the light square bishop and then
maybe the knight can come for example to
d7 to c5 to e 6 and control some very
import
central squares with Knight to c3 wife
just continues developing Bishop
captures Queen captures and now comes
Knight B to d7 now the night is hoping
to come to see see if I wouldn't attack
on the Queen
it also comes would have come with an
attack against the d3 pawn which is a
very weak pawn and here white will have
an opportunity to trade bishop for knife
which white doesn't want to do as a
black Bishop is such an excellent
defender in this line and here you could
go immediately for d4 but white first
repairs that we have a three nights the
c5 as planned attacking the Queen and
the d3 pawn so you can either capture or
remove the Queen back with Queen to c2
and now comes c6
rook eight d1 white brings the the last
inactive piece into the game and now
Queen to c7 the connecting rod is
developing the Queen also getting your
queen out of that nasty D file and here
before just pushing the knight back
knight c6 which was the Knights plan all
along
now controlling the d4 NDF four squares
and here white finally pushes d4 as the
d3 is a weak one you don't want you
don't want it he captures we have Knight
captures on d4 and now Knight to d7
asking white what do you want to do here
now you could capture here let's say
rook captures and go f4 and this is one
such idea however you will be able to
push f5 to control the light squares you
have a dark square Bishop where you will
be able to control the dark squares it
is one way to go but grandiose finds a
different line he goes Knight c2e2 first
Knight captures with Bishop capture son
d4 and now comes b5 of course black ones
if possible captures captures then he
would have a semi-open file for his rook
there would be a lot of pressure against
the a3 pawn which white of course does
not want to allow so instead white just
goes night the g3 and now c5 again
forcing white to decide what to do we
have D captures and c5 d captors on c5
the bishop must go back bishop to a1 and
now just nice to be six increasing the
pressure against the c4 pawn so white is
forced to capture will see capture son
five a capture some B 5 and now 92 f5 so
here you can see that the knight and
Bishop are really you know working
together here going for the g7 pawn
ideas like Queen B 2 are coming to
really put pressure against the black
Kings side so black has to you know
watch out for these things first Knights
the c4 guarding the the b2 square but
also pressuring the a3 pawn and here and
alias finds a very nice move rook to d3
defending but also if black doesn't
capture on a 3 then rook to g3 is coming
so you kinda do have to capture or do
you but okay now in the game rook
captures on a3 was played with rook
captures and Knight captures with an
attack on the Queen and now comes Queen
to be to putting pressure on the g7 pawn
also attacking the knight here and here
black has either the option that was
played in the game but a very
interesting line is Knight to c4 just
attacking the Queen here and allowing
Queen captures on b5 and after that
happens Knights the d6 Knight captures
and now you cannot capture for example
if you capture with the Queen you lose
the rook or if you capture with the
bishop you lose the rook here so here
you have to go Ruby 8 with an attack on
the Queen and after Knights the eh now
if rook captures Queen Knight captures
Queen a white is still up a piece Queen
to d8 now not allowing the Knights to
escape and not preparing for Queen
captures sorry about that
as the rook is still attacking the Queen
here so here white takes this
opportunity just to just mess up a
black's pawn structure Knight to f6
check as you do have to give up the
piece G captures and only now move the
Queen what do you have this position
where black has this well fairly strong
passed pawn and the white managed to
mess up black's pawn structure so this
was one possibility black head but
neither she went for a different one he
played c4 which kind of makes more sense
you now the bishop is protecting the
knight on an a3 and also the knight
controls the pawn on d5 so Knight each
tries to keep everything in check but of
course the knight the bishop is not
overloaded you cannot guard g7 and the
knight on e3 so Knight captures on g7
you cannot capture because it's
checkmate so we have looked to see it
now black is ready to perhaps start
pushing the past bond which would be
very dangerous first Knight to f5 now
white is already threatening checkmate
with Queen to h8 there's only one good
way to prevent this and that is c3 this
is what Knight each played we have Queen
to see one now and now if you try
something like b4 here just to
illustrate what kind of a powerful
position this is for white you can't
allow Queen between g5 with Czech after
the King moves you go Queen f6 check
King g8 and now just rook to e3 black is
just falling apart here there's no
defenses so after going to see one night
each tried King to h8 not allowing Queen
to g5 to come with Czech Argand Elias
did play this it is the strongest move
now again threatening Queen to f6 but
now we have Queen to e5 simply
controlling the f6 square root 2 e 3 y 2
just keeps putting on pressure you can
never push c2 you really want to start
pushing your passport but for the moment
it is not possible so first before just
you know increasing the pressure also
now the thread is B 3 and B 2 and here
we have looked to g3 and this is the
really interesting moment in the game
that I really want you to check out even
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the the best continuation
for black how do you keep everything in
order here how do you defend so you know
there's no right or wrong move I mean
there is a right move but I'm not like
asking you to find a move just you know
try to imagine you're playing black what
would you play here for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent defender because this
move is really really weird I don't
think anyone would play this like
probably an extremely strong defender if
you gave him a lot of time we'll find
the move but you know it's it's hard to
imagine a human would play this in the
game Bishop to c5 was played which
really allows the white to take
initiative the strongest move for black
is actually Bishop to g7 which seems
weird because the bishop is a
well-defended only twice and it's
attacked three times but the problem is
now if White's decides they are
we capture the bishop for example Queen
captures you get Queen captures rook
captures and now white keeps his extra
piece but the problem is b3 b2 is coming
and now after Bishop captures on c3 you
have to give up one piece to survive
rook captures rook captures on f7 and
now that the game can still continue
black is not in time to jet to win the
game just yet because of rook to f8
checkmate so first you have to make some
room for the King and then the black the
white rook is in time to prevent the the
black passed pawn and also after a
Bishop to g7 if you try Knight captures
then you just get Queen captures rook
captures now again you wrap a piece but
b3 is now just winning there you know
Bishop captures and c3 doesn't really
help you and b2 is coming so here after
rook to g3 Bishop to g7 the the
strongest move but I mean who would
actually play this rush of the c5 I was
played and disallowed grinnell used to
perform a beautiful maneuver and that is
night to h6 and now you see the problem
the threat of course is night to f7 this
will be checkmate if the night lands on
f7 the Queen is under attack and the
problem is if you trade Queens here
again you have the threat of checkmate
you have to deal with this for example
would rook to a fate but then you get
rook captures and G on c5 you lose a
piece so that's the problem with Bishop
to c5 but I mean who could who could
know such things
so here Knight each tried after Knight
to h6 Bishop captures an f2 with check
we have King captures and now Queen to
d4 check with King to f3 and now Queen
to d1 check and here neither
sorry a grand Ellis should have gone
King to f2 and then try to find you know
some safe heaven on on h2 he went F for
I we have Queen to d2 check and this is
the problem with King to f4 now after
King to f3 and I did to repeat the Queen
to d1 check but he should have gone for
captures and then just after captures
defend checkmate and the game the game
still continues you know b3 b2 still a
threat not not for the moment you can
play b2 right now because b3 right now
because c3 will be hanging but let's say
Knight C to the bishop doesn't
they have anywhere to go it would be it
would be playable for black here Queen
to d1 was repeated and now King to have
to finally Greendale is you know and
gets away with the King Queen to d4
check but now Queen to e3 blocking
grandiose does not want to repeat that
King F 3 to F 4 walk Queen captures we
have King captures and now rope to f8
the checkmate is no longer possible but
here we have a beautiful move again feel
free to pause the video here and you
know how would you continue this
position with black wood white know that
Knights the c2 is a threat you can lose
the bishop here
but even that keeping that in mind you
know what would you play here feel free
to pause the video and try to find it
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just you know
solved the mystery of why I even decided
to show this video it was actually this
position that really got me to like this
game here King to d4 was played and it's
really beautiful because you still fall
fall for this fork Knight see to check
where you lose the bishop but King g5
and now after Knight captures King f6
and out whatever black plays you're
getting checkmate it forever
for example a pawn - C - now do you see
the checkmate
of course you do ugh check forcing black
to take with the rook and now Knight
captures on f7 a nice smothered mate
where the King controls g7 beautiful
stuff Robert okay after King before of
course night II saw this and he decided
to play f6 here not allowing the King to
come to u 5 but it doesn't matter here
King to defy was played and it was in
this position on move 45 that a
grandmaster from azerbaijan orchid in
irish resigned the game why did you
resign well whatever you play here for
example you cannot push b3 is just too
slow if people see to you immediately
get Bishop captures rook captures and
the rogue g8 checkmate on the other hand
if you try some night maneuvers let's
say Knight b5 just King e6 and after
Knight try something you will at some
point attack the rook and the rook will
have to move let's say R ok 8 and now
Knight f7 will again be checkmate so
pretty much everything to play here not
pretty much anything to play here and in
checkmate
white just has this amazing amazing
position but this is just the really fun
part you know you're afraid of night c2
and then you're just not a problem King
before you run into the fork I just can
be five and it's all over yeah that's
the game mills gonna do loose vs. are
cutting Irish from round four of the
2019 defeated World Team Championship I
did prepare the standings after round
four so we don't forget here they are
it's from the official feed a website I
will put a link in the description below
so you can check it out and also there
you're more than welcome to follow the
live streams every day in first place
Russia are still holding with seven
match points India now with six match
points in second place United States
six points second place England six
points second place Iran fifth place
with five points then we have Kazakhstan
with four points China with three points
kind of hard to believe but you know
it's just not not their championship
Sweden with this great victory from
Neil's gonna Delius finally with a match
point so in eighth place with two points
Azerbaijan
another loss so only one match point in
Egypt without a team victory so far so
there we have it that was the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you are
enjoying my short coverage of this
championship so far I would like to
thank Russell Lloyd de Boer Andrews
later informed and Arman Book for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
- really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos your think all for watching and I
will see you soon with some more
interesting content hopefully you know
continuing the Capablanca saga checking
up on your suggestions and you know
doing what we usually do so thank you
all and have an excellent rest of your
Friday